is it normal to have a fat tongue and is
there any way to make it thinner yeah
sure
like if you just join a planet fitness
or something and you just like
to be or not to be that's a question you
asked me other questions and i'm about
to answer them on this episode of
responding to comments
kaylee mullins is it harmful to eat
scabs
scab ew is it harmful oh my god unless
it's like a
pus fill no just don't do it broken mask
panda the person question why do my
hands prune up really fast my hands
begin to prune in five minutes
are you just like pruning while living
or are you like pruning
while you're pruning your bushes are you
pruning in the tub
are you pruning in the club what up bub
that went from a very medical answer
to a very dr seuss answer burny beans is
there any way to improve memory use it
or you lose it how did i develop a good
memory i'm sure genetics are a part of
it but i remember when i was in third
grade
you know what my savage father made me
do when i had a reading assignment in
social studies
he'd make me recite the chapters word by
word while he looks at the book
i get one word wrong he kindly hands me
the book back and i go back in my room
and try and memorize it
you use it you peruse it calls them
visit
question is it normal to feel physical
pain when you're in emotional distress
yes i have a whole video on how emotions
cause physical pain and i'll tell you
something about covid19
during this time when anxiety is an
all-time high
you would think my practice would be
filled with patients coming in talking
about their anxiety and depression
no it's patients who have never
experienced physical discomfort meaning
no aches no pains no injuries are now
having shoulder aches neck aches back
aches muscle spasms
and they don't know why because your
emotions
play an integral part in your physical
health your mental state
your stress levels are all connected to
your physical health
mind body it's one word not only are we
connected from a neurological standpoint
meaning that nerves are traveling and
sending signals through
but we're also connected through an
endocrinological why can't i say that
endocrinological not chronological
endocrine system also connects your mind
and body and if you're
in a prolonged state for a chronic
amount of time you can have results
in your physical health does it matter
if you drink water while standing up
or sitting down does it matter
is this like a philosophical question
brian shrek
why does my eye twitch
i answered this question on the today
show and i may have given
the corniest joke uniquely enough it
does occur
more in women so guys out there she is
not winking at you yeah her eye just
might be twitching
i don't think it was funny do you think
it was funny anyway i twitch generally
harmless but some individuals can be
predisposed to it risk factors for
developing an eye twitch
stress obviously so we need to meditate
calm down a little bit more be more
mindful
over caffeination there's people that
are drinking 400 500 milligrams of
caffeine
in their coffees that's too much eye
strain from cell phones computers
constantly staring at a screen all day
do some relaxation exercises take a
break every 20 minutes and
if it's happening quite frequently and
you don't have an
answer as to why it's happening and it
won't go away
or it's really bad where it interferes
with your vision
that's a reason to go see your doctor
because there are true conditions out
there that can cause an eye twitch that
aren't just related to your lifestyle
habits
kian alvarado what is the best way to
get rid of warts on the bottom of the
foot a procedure i
commonly do in the office known as
cryotherapy
it sounds like you're getting in a
chamber and you're freezing yourself but
you're not doing that to your body
you're just doing it to the wart itself
in fact there are some kits that are
available over the counter
that you can buy and do this on your own
but if you want a surefire way to get
rid of the awards
come into our office usually it takes a
couple of sessions to fully get rid of
the wards
but my patients see great results and
it's really rare to have any adverse
effects
grace wisnoski why do we sweat
sweating sucks arid works
right isn't that the commercial sweat
stinks
that's an old commercial god i'm aging
myself it only seems to make me more hot
and uncomfortable well it certainly
makes you uncomfortable but it's
actually
making you less hot because when you
sweat you perspire the water evaporates
off your skin thereby cooling the
surface of your skin thereby cooling the
blood below the skin thereby cooling
your internal organs and you see where
i'm going with this it's
thermoregulation if you were to overheat
you'd be running a fever your body
wouldn't be performing optimally and you
would eventually
die if you didn't sweat so thank your
pores
hug them appreciate the moisture that
leaves your body
cheesy weenie at what part of becoming a
doctor process did you take your oath
what was it like
you know like i think most medical
schools don't even make you take a
proper oath but i remember we did i
believe it was during my white coat
ceremony which happens at the end of
your second year and you go into your
clinical rotations you say it out loud
in an auditorium with your fellow
classmates
it was powerful some people had tears in
their eyes i tend to not get too
emotional
because i'm dead inside
lauren farkas question does cranberry
juice really help treat utis the
evidence on this
is quite weak the reason we recommend it
is it's kind of benign unless you're
diabetic and you're getting a huge sugar
load the theory was
if you drink cranberry juice you will
then acidify your urine somewhat
and then by having your urine be more
acidic it would thereby decrease the
bacteria colonies
in your urinary tract now when we looked
at research
it's kind of been weak to non-existent
when it comes to cranberry juice i know
a lot of patients that still do it
because they
like natural remedies but the end of the
day if you have a true urinary tract
infection
you're symptomatic you don't want it to
spread higher in your urinary tract to
your kidneys and develop a pyloritis
because that's already a serious serious
condition because complicated
pyelonephritis could warrant
iv antibiotics tristan drum i burnt my
hand
really bad last night but today it's not
hurting but i also lost a sense of touch
in my fingertips is this normal is it
normal when you have damage to your hand
that you experience
possible neurologic symptoms yes is it
ideal no
should you be evaluated by a doctor yes
something else that happens when you
have a burn on your hand you can
experience contractures
which is actually the skin the scar
tissue that's being laid down
in lieu of the skin can actually
contract a little bit and your hand
might not be as flexible
so these are all reasons that you should
be consulting your doctor to make sure
you have an
optimal healing process daryl holland
quest junior
what's the importance of sleep for
adults over 50. well the importance of
sleep for those over 50 is the same that
it is
under 50 maintenance repair and
preparation for the next day
so get those seven to nine hours of
sleep but just remember we've created a
new age category for those over the age
of 65 where the sleep requirements drop
by an hour or two and the reason for
that is
it's harder to get the full seven to
nine hours it's harder to stay asleep
as you get older the mechanisms in your
brain sort of change
getting a little bit less once you're 65
plus maybe normal for you
how do you know when you should go to a
specialist rather than your primary care
doctor or pediatrician
or when you should go from one
specialist to another for the same
reason you should in my opinion
almost always go to see a primary care
doctor first especially if you have a
good relationship
a long lasting one because then they can
guide you and tell you whether or not
you need to see a specialist
most reasons patients when they come to
see me can be treated right then and
there
trinity question i have a double chin
but i'm not obese and i'm healthy
what is it and how do i fix it difficult
question trinity because i would need to
see the shape of your face the quality
of your skin
your age all of these things are taken
into consideration when we talk about
your appearance that being said i'm not
a plastic surgeon i'm not a
dermatologist
so i don't perform procedures like
injections skin tightening
creams even facelifts all of those are
potential options
remember unless you have a very enlarged
let's say
neck which can predispose you to having
sleep apnea
perhaps you know there's a thyroid issue
going on you're gonna be fine
and the fact that you have a double chin
will not affect your life
from a physical standpoint but if it
makes you unhappy then it might be worth
looking into
jamarcus lopez what can people do to
prevent
seizures it really depends on what
causes your seizures and a lot of times
especially for a first time seizure we
don't know the answer to that when i
worked on the pediatric ward when i was
a resident we would have
patients that would come in following a
seizure protocol where we would actually
try to induce the seizures
while monitoring their brain waves and
things that we used to do
include sleep deprivation intense light
therapy with like flashing uh lights
the question i would pose to you would
be a
how do you know it's definitely a
seizure that you're experiencing b have
you seen a neurologist to figure out
what type of seizure disorder you have
and c
figure out what your triggers are and a
lot of times that means asking you
questions so you can figure out what the
triggers are
sarcophagus i recently had a blood test
and it turns out i'm deficient in the
four vitamins
h-u-g and s can you provide
supplementation
i think we're probably gonna have to
supplement quite heavily on this
i think i'm gonna create my own line of
supplements in these vitamins because
i like giving them away and i won't
charge for them i'm just gonna give them
away for free and i know you probably
are thinking mike that's not a good
business model how are you gonna make
money on these supplements
but the real reward comes from the
actual
hugs if you didn't get it yet
where you been welcome the tv show
friends is one of my all-time favorites
check out the medical scenes from there
some of them are pretty legit and if
you're a fan of scrubs how did you miss
this
click click click click yo bear where
you at
click stay happy and healthy